hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to another crying fear
custom campaign this time recidivists I
just gotta say I freaking love cry fear
I love team psycho hi sighs Geller I
wish they got paid for what they do cuz
they deserve it man
I fear it's just an incredible thing I
hope they all get hired by valve cuz I
know valve was talking like they wanted
to bring more you know gripping hoard of
playing to people's emotions
introduction I'm alone I am alone no
well I have forced everyone away from me
because I must be alone as a Simon I am
a disease eating away at the kindness
others have shown me I have chosen to
render myself dead to the world just as
my legs have become dead to me that's
Simon and that was actually the voice
actor I think oh well now oops I think
is gone til it'll be dirty in here like
seriously I love teams i scar if they're
like if they ever watch any of my videos
I'd be surprised that they do seriously
they're great guys like just an awesome
team to dedicate themselves to something
like this I'm creating something for the
community Simon how are you feeling
today
oh I feel fine dr. Adams well you don't
look fine Simon how have you been
sleeping huh fine now
Simon if we're gonna make any progress
here you're gonna have to open up a
little okay why the hell would I open up
to you yeah yeah I may as well be
talking to a brick wall
uh-huh dr. Pernell listen he heard me he
tried to understand I don't know if I'm
supposed to move forward yet cuz the
voices had come from over here his death
must have taken quite a toll on you yeah
did I do that
I called Sophie and I asked her to come
and see you
she asked this is it in a long time and
I thought call her back and tell her not
to come here yeah ah it was a kind
gesture dr. Adams but I can't see her
uh-huh I told her to stop coming
my happiness came to depend yeah the
voices are over there more and more each
visit wore her down until the look in
her eyes said nothing but pity yeah I'm
a burden mmm legs or not I was always a
burden yeah Simon I what that I have to
take this Simon but I want to talk about
this when I get back
uh-huh okay man it's really cool they've
got the original voice actor in here I'm
wondering how in-depth this custom
campaign is maybe I picked a winner
oh hello is anybody
I can't stray from this path it said or
else I'll probably die probably oh wait
a minute I don't like this whole
spotlight business maybe I'm just like
freaked out cuz I don't like woods
because of all the slender I've been
playing recently but this jump scares
coming up around the corner I didn't
know something's gonna happen it's gonna
happen it's obvious it huh huh come on
it's so far away oh oh no oh no
he's so quiet oh don't do it don't do it
don't do it
oh nothing happen oh god where what are
they doing to me I'm like flipping out
and nothing's happened yet
I can't freak out this early I'm just
starting okay okay okay I'm gonna assume
that nothing's gonna happen well maybe
they're just trying to lull me into a
false sense of security that's probably
it
that sounds like exactly what they do II
see aha
oh no oh what the hell those hands
they're twitching oh oh oh my I don't
want to go near the oh god okay three
four this man what the hell is with
those arms I thought I might turn around
something to be run No Oh what does that
say what does that say oh that's a
pencil grab a de pistol oh don't shoot
yourself don't do it oh I see who this
might actually be a lengthy custom
campaign I love it
oh okay
oh this is comforting hang on I got a
double check always be thorough check
everything we can this stuff on the
other side there was nothing over here
anyway oh the good old running juice I
love me some running juice that door
won't budge the door won't budge the
door budge did I did not expect that
miss Lam oh I still don't have a pistol
yet okay looks like things have kind of
collapsed here but I'm starting to guess
that the whole of reality is going to
unravel very soon usually happens this
game's okay come on budge one budget one
bite it's a different door sound okay
looks positively cheerful in here what
was that huh huh hey The Doors won't
budge I guess I'm out of here
I don't like this ah no no no no no no
dark it's dark why is it dark oh oh oh
okay it's cool nice level design kitchen
I can't go to the kitchen door it won't
budge of course
this place looks old obviously because
trees are starting to bust out of the
ground probably bad okay yes yes yes I
got it okay got a key here kitchen key
Oh perfect hang on let me double-check
down here
sure there's nothing of value what was
that
anything in here no oh god it's really
dark and scary
oh no I'm brave okay shut off the power
to the keypad house they're even still
power in this place what that it lagged
again every time that happens I think
something gonna happen
get the kitchen key let's go to the
kitchen cuz that's a great idea actually
going anywhere is not a great idea oh
what's that why does it keep doing that
where does it keep pausing hmm might
just be a computer thing I don't know
never had trouble running crap here
before seems like it's locked from the
other side well isn't that fantastic
good an open door oh look pots and pans
I hear that I hear that I hear that
uh-huh look a baton and a key this could
be use ha ha ha oh it's you little kitty
Oh God oh don't let me now
look please your boot I'll get warm I'm
gonna get comes the bunk machine oh oh
you ain't got a chance against the bunk
mill yeah Oh meow oh no aah come on
I think the game's crashing no it did
not crash I don't know what's goin going
on about that sorry about the delays
but hopefully it won't be that bad huh I
got to put town and the will and the
drive to bonk it
Oh should find my phone Simon needs to
find his phone mmm security room key
where is the security room I don't
remember seeing that okay all done
recorded thoughts and memories cuz
that's normal
this one yeah okay good guess markiplier
thank you Oh hmm I got a bunker don't
don't mess with me you all will miss me
I got J bunker nothing o'clock and
you're dead now enemies phone home phone
gun oh okay
warning low battery that's that's not
good yep it's gonna die it's gonna die
why'd you take like 15 bullets oh and my
phone died just been in there you son of
a [ __ ] phone [ __ ]
oh oh I should look for a battery in
here oh come on
all right just hi what no I did not do
that okay oh I see it will like looped
me right back around oh okay yay bloop
bloop oh combine with Luke come on okay
there we go and now we're back up is son
of a [ __ ] phone oh oh oh
bug are we go oh hey mom
yeah I'm sure you're still alive it is
nice to be in Simon's shoes like
officially Simon's shoes again because I
kind of feel like this is a continuation
of a story oh I was fun ooh
turn the light
and let me go back and save
let me save please save yes please
thank you thank you don't go oh here we
go in to the darkness
I love the darkness huh is there
anything up there no dot huh who are
some I'm way to go for you good my phone
ok ha
I like that transition not really and
not at all because it's freaks me out
ah damn it Simon stop dancing around and
pay attention you got monsters here once
again psychotic creations of your own
depraved mind and you gotta take care of
them and bye take care of I mean kill
kill dead kill them dead kill them so
dead hello hello look hello hello hello
and look at statue huh I wonder if they
made some custom stuff for this piston
campaign you don't no one will see that
why is that chained up I only know of
one reason why things would be chained
up change on man statue huh it's on the
end of the water can't get in
alright nothing so far things look okay
yeah I can't even they won't even let me
get in the water
invisible walls and all that hello
okay alright
actually I'm out of time for the first
episode thank you so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotations
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye